[Musique]
c'est papa pourquoi aucun bazar cie
zineb el rhazoui qui était finaliste
charlie qui avait échappé à la tuerie et
des frères cauchy avait appelé avait
surnommé l'observatoire de la laïcité
l'abattoir de la laïcité tout simplement
pas ce pour jean louis bianco et nicolas
cadène la laïcité c'est de soi doit se
rapprocher d'une d'une tolérance à
l'anglo saxonne et il s'est pas du tout
la laïcité à la française
donc il est pas quand même complètement
infondée que le gouvernant alors qui
prend conscience qu'ils prenaient
conscience au mois d'octobre après
l'assassinât de sa mère pattie que
certaines organisations étaient quand
des chevilles ouvrières des
développements dont et qu'ils voulaient
faire avancer leur agenda politique
qu'on en finisse avec cette orientation
d'observateurs de la laïcité
cette instance est telle qu'elle est et
légumes partial nommé par le premier
ministre certes mais un dépanneur
alors que on sentait bien que ce qui
peut venir je sais pas mais ce qui peut
venir c'est une reprise en main en
quelque sorte de 200 observateurs et des
arbres alors que c'est pas à mon avis
c'est pas le but c'est ce que c'est
parce que je souhaite personnellement
qu'elle reçoit quelqu'un à ce niveau là
je souhaite recevoir leurs représentants
du gouvernement ou à quelqu'un qui
polémiquent de 1,16 par plier je
souhaite recevoir quelqu'un qui parle
d'une manière impartiale de la loire de
la licité telle qu'elle est et c'est
important par rapport aux jeunes parce
que dans nos quartiers la laïcité les
perçu comme une agression
bien sûr un an ce qui se passe d'un
débat télévisé
elle est perçue comme une agression
j'ai l'impression que depuis un certain
nombre d'années on l'a on a un petit peu
réduite à la loi 1905 la laïcité c'est
pas seulement la loi de 1905
c'est aussi la loi de 2004 monsieur la
dînée mais c'est aussi comme une manière
de vivre en commun de favoriser le
commet là discret notamment ça induit et
jean pierre chevènement laver laver qui
en son temps une également un minimum de
discrétion des religions dans l'espace
public
je pense que globalement il est respecté
et respectés même et accepté bien
évidemment au niveau des établissements
scolaires par exemple aucun problème de
la loi de ménage ou globalement vraiment
je ne renie yahia une obéissance et
disons des populations des populations
concernées à à la loire il n'y a pas de
problème j'ai bien globalement apprécié
on commence à correspondre avec
l'islamisme radical au pire avec le
terrorisme bien sûr mais la laïcité elle
n'est pas la solution à tout
l on voit ce que vous faire passer les
sénateurs ce que l'on veut me faire
passer le sénateur avec les amendements
qu'ils ont tués on voit très bien que
l'utilisation politique du problème
vient des politiciens est pas politique
je lisais des amendements qui aurait été
fait il ya un amendement qui vise à
interdire tout signe ostentatoire
l'instant si ce n'est pas la même chose
d'ailleurs dans la rue au les jeunes ou
les mineurs mais ça veut dire quoi
serviront connais pas du tout mais le
réel ne savais absolument plus rien dire
donc cessons de faire de la laïcité
leleu ne soit design sans visa solution
la plus probable
on voit bien que l'agenda politique des
gens qui veulent une laïcité à ce qu'on
appelle parce que comme henri michaux
reste appel à la laïcité adjectif alors
il ya nichols nicolas sarkozy qui avait
parlé de laïcité positive puisqu'il ya
la laïcité les tenants de la laïcité
ouverte à nantes il ya la laïcité points
et est donc cette comment cette laïcité
aujourd'hui elle est on a comme
aujourd'hui une laïcité qui attaqué de
toutes parts toutes parts par des gens
qui ont un agenda l'histoire et qui ne
s'en cache pas et je trouve dommage de
trouver comment que l'observateur
dualiste et qui est téléchargé plutôt de
2,2 de lutter contre ça c'en est fait le
con le le propagateur et c'est la fin de
cette première partie de la matinale on
se retrouve dans moins de quatre minutes
reste avec nous
[Musique]